how old were you when you started
playing guitar i think 14
14. yeah up until then no music lessons
nothing like that yeah i had
uh uh i had to take piano lessons and
you hated it i
hated it and the guitar was your
salvation because you knew you wanted to
be a musician in some weird way and then
you get a hold of a guitar and you start
playing
and did someone teach you to play the
guitar or you just learned that on your
own
i did learn it on my own that's [ __ ]
crazy to me how you doing
how old are you when you write your
first song uh i think it was 15.
15. yeah and the band hated it so
i fired him and it took you a long time
to figure out how to sing in the sense
that um
still figuring it out i was listening to
an early this is an early record
recording and you were you you were
trying to find your voice i feel
like and you almost sounded like more
like robert plant
than the guy you sound like today am i
correct i'm going to play a little this
tell
tell me what comes to mind
all three of them but when you're an
artist and you start thinking about
doing a band and all that stuff
don't you get sort of confused uh in
terms of like
when do you find your style that we all
know today well
you do it a lot right you tour a lot and
you you build up confidence you build up
confidence within
your little family around you and they
guide you too
you know you can you ask questions like
what does that sound like or
you know you listen to yourself back and
you go wow i'd rather not sound like
that
i noticed i noticed a big um because
even in the early days
when we're playing clubs and stuff
around la and san francisco james was so
shy that he didn't even used to talk to
the audience dave mustain our guitar
player used to do all the talking
right i noticed the biggest
transformation was when the first time
we went to europe
in 1984 we got out in front of the
european audiences
and there were thousands of them just
welcoming us you know and they've been
waiting for us for a couple years
and i noticed a big change in james he
all of a sudden started finding himself
and
communicating with the audience and
getting a lot more confident yeah
and that's a tough thing to develop it
just happens with thousands of hours of
practice